حلّال القيم الذاتية الكمي التباينيّ أو VQE هو أحد أقدم الخوارزميات الهجينة الكمية-الكلاسيكية وهو
مثير للاهتمام لعدة أسباب. أولاً، كما سنرى في هذا الفيديو، هو نهج واعد لبعض أنواع المسائل. ثانياً، هو مهم
تاريخياً ومهّد الطريق للعديد من الخوارزميات المحسّنة مثل adapt VQE.
وأخيراً، VQE بسيط إلى حد ما. من السهل فهم ما يفعله الحاسوب الكمي والكلاسيكي في هذه الخوارزمية
وكيف يتفاعلان. هناك أربعة مكونات رئيسية لحساب VQE.
أولاً، هناك مؤثر، غالباً هاملتونيان، سنسميه H، يصف خاصية للنظام
تريد تحسينها. طريقة أخرى لقول ذلك هي أنك تبحث عن المتجه الذاتي لهذا المؤثر الذي
يقابل القيمة الذاتية الأدنى. غالباً ما نسمي ذلك المتجه الذاتي بالحالة الأرضية.
بعد ذلك، هناك ansatz وهي كلمة تعني المقاربة. هذا circuit كمي يُعدّ حالة كمية تقرّب
المتجه الذاتي الذي تبحث عنه. في الحقيقة، الـ ansatz هو عائلة من الـ circuit الكمية لأن بعض الـ gate في
الـ ansatz مُعلمنة. أي يتم تغذيتها بمعامل يمكننا تغييره. هذه العائلة من الـ circuit الكمية
يمكنها إعداد عائلة من الحالات الكمية التي تقرّب الحالة الأرضية.
بعد ذلك، نحتاج مُقدِّراً، وسيلة لتقدير القيمة المتوقعة للمؤثر H على الحالة الكمية
التباينية الحالية. أحياناً ما يهمنا فعلاً هو ببساطة هذه القيمة المتوقعة، التي
نسميها دالة التكلفة. وأحياناً أخرى نهتم بدالة أكثر تعقيداً يمكن كتابتها انطلاقاً من
قيمة متوقعة واحدة أو أكثر.
أخيراً، نحتاج مُحسِّناً كلاسيكياً، خوارزمية تغير المعاملات لمحاولة تقليل دالة التكلفة.
دعونا نحدد المسألة التي نريد حلها والنهج العام قبل أن نتناول كيف يلعب الحاسوب الكمي دوراً.
يمكننا صياغة العديد من مسائل التحسين الحاسمة للعلم والصناعة كمسائل قيم ذاتية لمصفوفة. عادةً،
تريد القيمة الذاتية الأدنى لمصفوفتك والمتجه الذاتي المقابل لها. المصفوفة H يمكن أن تكون
هاملتونيان يصف طاقة نظام فيزيائي. والقيمة الذاتية الأدنى ستكون طاقة الحالة الأرضية
E0 والمتجه الذاتي سيكون الحالة الأرضية الكمية المقابلة والتي تُرمز عادة بـ psi الفرعية 0.
أو المصفوفة يمكن أن تصف دالة تكلفة معقدة مرتبطة بمسائل التحسين التوافقي
مثل مسائل اللوجستيات والحالة الذاتية s الفرعية opt ستكون حلاً أمثل
للمسألة مثل سلسلة ثنائية تُسمّي قطعاً في رسم بياني لشبكة توزيع. عملياً
من الشائع سماع مصطلح هاملتونيان لجميع المصفوفات المعنية حتى خارج العلوم الفيزيائية. لنقل
أننا مهتمون بمصفوفة ذات n صف وn عمود. مثل هذه المسائل يمكن حلها بسرعة ودقة باستخدام
حلّالات كلاسيكية لـ n حتى بضع مئات أو آلاف بدون افتراضات عن المصفوفة. للمصفوفات المتفرقة،
تلك التي معظم مدخلاتها أصفار، يمكن أن يكون هذا أكبر بكثير مع n يصل إلى مليار حتى على حاسوب محمول.
لكن للمسائل الضخمة حقاً التي تتجاوز هذه الأرقام، غالباً ما تكون هناك حاجة لطرق تقريبية أو تجريبية.
كلما كانت المصفوفة أكبر وأقل تفرقاً، كلما كانت المسألة أصعب وكلما احتجت حيلاً أذكى. لنفترض أن مصفوفتك كبيرة
لدرجة أن التقطير الدقيق ليس خياراً. ولنفترض أيضاً أنك تعرف ما يكفي عن مسألتك لتقدم
بعض التخمينات عن البنية العامة للحالة المستهدفة وتريد استكشاف حالات مشابهة لتخمينك
الأولي لمعرفة إن كان يمكن خفض التكلفة أو الطاقة أكثر. هذا هو النهج التباينيّ وهو إحدى الطرق
المستخدمة عندما لا يكون التقطير الدقيق خياراً على حاسوب كلاسيكي. سيعمل كالتالي.
أولاً، تقدم حالة تخمينية ببعض المعاملات theta التي ستغيرها.
رغم أن هذا التخمين الأولي يمكن أن يكون عشوائياً، فهذا غير مستحسن. نريد استخدام معرفتنا بالمسألة المطروحة
لتخصيص تخميننا قدر الإمكان.
ثانياً، نحسب القيمة المتوقعة للمؤثر مع النظام في تلك الحالة.
ثالثاً، نغير المعاملات التباينية ونكرر.
رابعاً، نستخدم المعلومات المتراكمة عن مشهد الحالات الممكنة في فضائك الفرعي التباينيّ لتقديم تخمينات أفضل
والاقتراب من الحالة المستهدفة.
المبدأ التباينيّ يضمن أن حالتنا التباينية لا يمكن أن تعطي قيمة ذاتية أقل من تلك الخاصة
بالحالة الأرضية المستهدفة. إذن كلما انخفضت القيمة المتوقعة، كان تقريبنا للحالة الأرضية أفضل.
دعونا نتحدث عن صعوبة كل خطوة في هذا النهج.
ضبط أو تحديث المعاملات سهل حسابياً. الصعوبة هناك في اختيار معاملات أولية مفيدة
مُستوحاة فيزيائياً. استخدام المعلومات المتراكمة من التكرارات السابقة لتحديث المعاملات بطريقة
تقربك من الحالة الأرضية ليس بسيطاً. لكن خوارزميات التحسين الكلاسيكية موجودة وتفعل
ذلك بكفاءة جيدة. هذا التحسين الكلاسيكي مكلف فقط لأنه قد يتطلب العديد من
التكرارات. في أسوأ الحالات، قد يتزايد عدد التكرارات أسياً مع n.
الخطوة الأكثر تكلفة حسابياً هي بالتأكيد القيمة المتوقعة لمصفوفتك باستخدام
حالة معينة. المصفوفة ذات n في n يجب أن تعمل على المتجه ذي n عنصر مما يقابل من رتبة n تربيع
عملية ضرب في أسوأ الحالات. يجب أن يتم هذا عند كل تكرار للمعاملات. للمصفوفات الكبيرة
جداً، هذا له تكلفة حسابية عالية. الآن تخيل إسناد هذا الجزء من
الحساب إلى حاسوب كمي. بدلاً من حساب هذه القيمة المتوقعة، تقدّرها بإعداد
الحالة s لـ theta على الحاسوب الكمي باستخدام الـ ansatz التباينيّ ثم إجراء قياسات.
دعونا نفكك ذلك قليلاً. H عموماً ليس سهل القياس. مثلاً، قد يتكون من العديد من
مؤثرات باولي x وy وz غير المتبادلة.
لكن H يمكن كتابته كتركيبة خطية من حدود H الفرعية alpha كل منها سهل القياس. مثلاً،
مؤثرات باولي أو مجموعات من مؤثرات باولي المتبادلة بتياً.
القيمة المتوقعة لـ H على الحالة S هي المجموع الموزون للقيم المتوقعة للحدود المكونة H alpha.
هذا التعبير يصح لأي حالة S لكننا سنستخدمه تحديداً مع حالتنا التباينية S لـ theta.
كل حد من حدود h alpha يمكن قياسه m مرة مما يعطي عينات قياس s الفرعية alpha j حيث j تتراوح من
1 إلى m وتُرجع قيمة متوقعة وانحرافاً معيارياً. يمكننا جمع
هذه الحدود ونشر الأخطاء عبر المجموع.
هذا لا يتطلب ضرباً واسع النطاق ولا أي عملية تتناسب بالضرورة مع n تربيع. بدلاً من ذلك،
يتطلب قياسات متعددة على الحاسوب الكمي. إذا لم تكن بحاجة لعدد كبير منها، فقد يكون هذا النهج
فعالاً. وهذا هو الجزء الكمي من VQE. لكن دعونا نتحدث عن أسباب قد تجعل هذا غير فعال. سبب واحد
لكثرة القياسات هو تقليل عدم اليقين الإحصائي في تقديراتك لحسابات عالية
الدقة. سبب آخر هو عدد سلاسل باولي المطلوبة لامتداد مصفوفتك بالكامل. لأن مصفوفات باولي زائد
الوحدة تمتد في فضاء جميع المؤثرات ذات بُعد معين، فنحن مضمونون
أنه يمكننا كتابة مصفوفتنا المعنية كمجموع موزون لمؤثرات باولي كما فعلنا سابقاً. هنا C alpha هو
معامل عددي وH alpha هو سلسلة من مؤثرات باولي تعمل على جميع الـ qubit التي تصف نظامك.
H alpha سيكون بشكل مثل هذا حيث مؤثر باولي الـ n من اليمين يعمل على الـ qubit الـ n. إذن يمكننا
قياس مؤثرنا بقياس سلسلة من مؤثرات باولي. لكن لا يمكننا قياس كل مؤثرات باولي
تلك في آنٍ واحد. مؤثرات باولي باستثناء الوحدة لا تتبادل مع بعضها إذا كانت
مرتبطة بنفس الـ qubit. مثلاً، يمكننا قياس IZ وIIZ وZZ
وXZ في آنٍ واحد لأنه يمكننا قياس I وZ في آنٍ واحد للـ qubit
الثالث. ويمكننا معرفة I وX في آنٍ واحد للـ qubit الأول. لكن لا يمكننا
قياس كل Z's وZZ وZX في آنٍ واحد لأن Z وX لا
يتبادلان وكلاهما يعمل على الـ qubit الصفري.
إذن نحلل مصفوفتنا H إلى مجموع مؤثرات باولي تعمل على qubit مختلفة.
بعض عناصر ذلك المجموع يمكن قياسها دفعة واحدة. نسمي ذلك مجموعة من مؤثرات باولي المتبادلة. حسب
عدد الحدود غير المتبادلة، قد نحتاج العديد من هذه المجموعات. لنسمِّ عدد هذه المجموعات من مؤثرات باولي
المتبادلة ngcp.
إذا كان ngcp صغيراً، فقد يعمل هذا بشكل جيد.
إذا كان لـ H ملايين المجموعات، فهذا لن يكون مفيداً. تسجل القيمة المتوقعة أو دالة التكلفة
لمجموعة المعاملات theta المستخدمة في حالتك ثم تحدث المعاملات بمرور الوقت. يمكنك استخدام
القيم المتوقعة أو قيم دالة التكلفة التي قدّرتها لتقريب تدرج دالة التكلفة في
الفضاء الفرعي للحالات المُعيّنة بالـ ansatz الخاص بك.
توجد مُحسِّنات كلاسيكية مبنية على التدرج وأخرى بدون تدرج. كلاهما يعاني من مشاكل قابلية التدريب المحتملة مثل
الحدود الدنيا المحلية المتعددة والمناطق الكبيرة من فضاء المعاملات ذات التدرج شبه المعدوم والتي تُسمى الهضاب القاحلة.
فهل سيحل VQE جميع مسائلك الأصعب؟ لا. لكن أن يكون أفضل في كل الحسابات لم يكن الهدف أبداً.
لقد غيّرنا ما يحدد التكلفة الحسابية. انظر ما استبدلناه. تحولنا من عملية
تعقيدها يعتمد فقط على بُعد المصفوفة إلى عملية تعتمد على الدقة المطلوبة وعدد
مؤثرات باولي غير المتبادلة التي تشكل المصفوفة. الجزء الأخير ليس له نظير في الحوسبة الكلاسيكية.
بناءً على هذه التبعيات الجديدة، للمصفوفات المتفرقة أو المصفوفات التي تتضمن عدداً قليلاً من سلاسل باولي غير المتبادلة، قد تكون هذه
العملية مفيدة. هذا هو الحال لأنظمة اللف المغزلي المتفاعلة. مثلاً، للمصفوفات الكثيفة، قد تكون
أقل فائدة. نعلم مثلاً أن الأنظمة الكيميائية غالباً ما يكون لها هاملتونيان يتضمن مئات وآلاف بل
ملايين سلاسل باولي. تم إنجاز عمل مثير لتقليل هذا العدد من الحدود، لكن
الأنظمة الكيميائية قد تكون أكثر ملاءمة لبعض الخوارزميات الأخرى التي سنناقشها في هذه الدورة.
الاستخدام الفعال لـ VQE يتطلب أيضاً أن نعرف سمات حالتنا المستهدفة ونستطيع اختيار حالة أولية جيدة
مُستوحاة فيزيائياً بالإضافة إلى ansatz جيد بعدد قليل نسبياً من المعاملات التباينية. هذا يمكن أن يكون
صعباً جداً. يُظهر VQE كيف يمكن الجمع بين نقاط قوة الحواسيب الكلاسيكية والكمية
بدون إضافة طرق أحدث. VQE لا يساعدنا في حل مسائل مستعصية على الحواسيب الكلاسيكية، لكنه
يستمر في لعب دور في تطوير الخوارزميات. ويعلمنا VQE أيضاً أن نقل خطوة من الحوسبة الكلاسيكية
إلى الكمية ليس أفضل ولا أسوأ لجميع الأغراض. بل إنه
يغير العوامل التي تحدد كفاءة خوارزميتك. هذا درس عام مهم في الحوسبة
الهجينة الكلاسيكية-الكمية.